hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Gotham they did some big references to
Bane and venom in the comics as well as
some of the darker corners of Wayne
Enterprises so just like normal I'm
gonna start with my top five comic book
references and then I'll do my review
hello to any new people too if you're
just finding me for the first time I'm
doing all the DC TV shows Constantine
starts this Friday it's a good time for
comic book television so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
okay so just blanket spoiler warning for
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
top five moments number five Wayne
Enterprises is vast and pretty corrupt
so the real villains here are obviously
the board members that we don't see
they're just like the faceless power
behind Viper and venom there's this
really interesting relationship between
the super wealthy people and Gotham and
the big mobsters like Falcone and Maroni
some of the villains operate at night
like the mobsters some during the day in
an office but they're all bad I don't
know that they were specifically
intending to draw any references to the
board members but think of them as like
a nest of vipers as in the Viper drug
yes I definitely do think that
well-designed person at the end is
connected to one or more the board
members I don't think she was working
for Falcone and Maroni it's someone will
probably mean in a future episode that
was what that whole Bruce luncheon
moment was about you know I want to meet
with the board members if you remember
during Batman Begins that was actually
one of the big battles for Bruce Wayne
you know not necessarily Batman so they
could give that to young Bruce Wayne he
could battle the board this season and
that could be like his big fight they
don't talk about it too often but Wayne
Enterprises itself is vast like there
are many many sub companies the adult
Batman Bruce Wayne knows pretty much
about all of them but young Bruce Wayne
has no idea what's going on it just
makes a lot easier for the show to pull
villains out of the company if you
remember in the movies The Riddler
worked for Bruce Wayne I'm pretty sure
Wayne Enterprises own Dax's chemicals
where the Michael Keaton Joker was
created I think in the comics the name
was ace chemicals and it was actually
the Kane family to note it in the comics
that is the Kane family is where Bruce
Wayne's mother comes from they're like
the other wealthy family in Gotham or
the other wealthiest family they haven't
talked about it too much but Bruce
Wayne's parents were basically like from
the two wealthiest families in the city
it'd be like if two Royals got married
you know the two wealthiest people in
Gotham that kind of makes their murder
seemed like register
I don't know that Gotham specifically
gonna address the Kane family but
Gordon's former fiancee is Barbara Kean
and they're just another super-rich
family number four the Russian mob in
the comics the Russian mob has just
worked a lot with black masks on the
show it just seems like the Russian is
more of a puppet of Muniz inner coup
against Falcone there was a man in the
mask in the Halloween promo after the
episode but I don't think that they're
going to be doing black masks on the
show their big thing has been showing
people before they became the big comic
book characters number three Gotham
University this actually appeared in the
comics for the first time in 1941 in
more recent years they've used it as
like the daytime haunt of Batgirl like
she goes to school there when she's not
fighting crime there was also another
student there about the same time in the
comics called bat devil and he became
the future version of Azrael it's just
one of the other big locations for the
show to pull villains out of Bruce is
way too young to go there right now so
most of the time when we see it it'll be
like Gordon going there to investigate
someone I do think that Gotham
University is gonna have something to do
with the Batman vs Superman movie though
number 2 world's greatest detective this
was actually one of my favorite arcs
during the episode I felt like this was
stronger than the venom arc Bruce
himself is supposed to be between 11 and
13 on the show so I give them a blanket
pass on how clever he's allowed to be
Batman isn't a genius but he is really
intelligent it just never stops working
he's like the king of homework or
detective work which I guess are almost
the same thing to my favorite scenes
though were when he was putting his
evidence board together at the beginning
I'm guessing he just doesn't have his
supercomputer yet and then the part at
the end when Alfred joined him really
excitedly like he finally gets that it's
something really important and positive
Batman is a bit of an
obsessive-compulsive when it comes to
solving mysteries so they might show
Bruce going overboard this season and
Alfred just slapping him back into
sanity I don't expect David Mizzou's to
get too strung out but I mean obviously
at some point they have to show Bruce
trying to push himself too hard and my
number one comic book moment all the
venom in the episode it was Viper it was
like the precursor to venom but they did
say that they had a working venom serum
well zine was the company behind it
there's subsidiary of Wayne Enterprises
and there's probably a board member
that's behind it all controlling every
I think the question now though is what
is the show going to do with the venom I
mean if they have a working serum are
they going to start selling it I don't
expect them to do Bane anytime soon
just because his character seems so far
into the future I do think that Welles
I'm the company is gonna continue to be
a big thing in the plot if you were
confused by what the villains were doing
in the episode they were basically being
terrorists in the name of humanity in
like they're really crackpot way they're
trying to show people that well Zion was
an evil company just based on the way
everything is shaping up I'm starting to
wonder if the Wayne's murder
Arkham City as well as well Zion are all
connected like they all have something
to do with the reason the Wayne's were
murdered I feel like we'll have enough
information to start making some better
theories by the middle of this season
which is actually only a couple of weeks
away let me know that what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what did you think of the Viper special
effects it kind of reminded me of the
Batman and Robin movie whenever Bane's
muscles started growing also here are a
few other Easter eggs I spotted so Bruce
Wayne being into old Zorro flicks
obviously masked man and all very clear
teaser for the cape and cowl then there
was Betty Kane supposedly she was
supposed to be in the episode but we
didn't see her or maybe they just cut
her out she was at the original Batgirl
in the comics IMDB is listing Sara
Paxton is playing her she's supposed to
be in like 17 episodes and they're only
gonna be 22 total this season this was
episode 5 so I guess that means she's
gonna be in all the episodes from here
to the end of the season unless there's
some sort of error it will be pretty bad
asked to get like a Batgirl character on
the show so overall I gave the episode a
solid B I feel like the Bruce detective
storyline was the strongest the venom
parts got a little bit silly but I kind
of think that was the point I think it
was meant to be a little bit can't be
like the classic TV show especially when
they did the whole gallon of milk
challenge I know a lot of people seemed
confused as to whether or not they're
supposed to take things seriously on the
show like when it's being campy and
cheesy it's intentional like they write
it to be that way
it's not supposed to be a super hardcore
like Chris Nolan's trilogy I did feel
like the Viper storyline was a bit of a
dead end but I think it's gonna turn
into something bigger like those well
zine Wayne Enterprises mysterious board
member thing I feel like they're turning
that into one of the big arcs for the
season which actually ended up giving us
a whole lot more David Mizzou's
I really liked his public Bruce Wayne
it's like he's wearing a mask when he's
in public like the detective Bruce Wayne
that's more of the Batman persona that's
what he's really like when he's in
public you know he's much more wooden
faced that's why he seems so patient and
cool whenever he was talking to the well
sign woman trying to get a meeting with
the board members it's always
interesting to see when a new actor
plays Bruce Wayne how they played the
public Bruce Wayne versus the Batman
character I think Christian Bale's was
obviously like a real-life stark
contrast between Batman voice and the
douchey looking Bruce that drove around
in Lamborghinis David mezuzahs just
being a little bit more so with it so
far
I wasn't digging the mob storyline quite
as much you know the Maroni versus
Falcone as well as fish Mooney's coos
storyline I mean she had a really sexy
scene at the end and everything looked
visually very amazing but I feel like
this week the detectives storyline was
just way more interesting it did feel
like they wanted that Falcone scene at
the end to feel really grand and epic
and it looked just really mind-blowing
with the way they panned up on Gotham
City but I just couldn't buy the earbud
sharing at the end I just kind of had to
ignore that part Mooney in general just
doesn't feel like a threatening villain
to Falcone to be fair it's really hard
to stand out as a Batman villain if
you're not wearing clown makeup
and slicing people's faces up every week
the biggest vibe that I'm actually
getting from Muniz camp right now is
like the sultry temptress you know more
poison ivy which is interesting because
we already had that character on the
show even though we haven't seen her in
a couple weeks next week is the
Halloween episode so I do have high
hopes for craziness so important news
Constantine starts this Friday I will be
doing videos every week so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff I have
seen the pilot episode so I might post a
non-spoilery review of that in the next
couple of days before they have changed
some things from the original pilot so
I'm not sure which version of that
they're gonna air but you can click here
to learn more about that series and
click here for my Gotham episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you